religion is part of society and how it
functions
that's just an inescapable fact and
religions of course also functions
differently in different parts of the
world this becomes especially apparent
when we talk about subjects like
migration and globalization for example
in 2015 as most of you probably know
there was a refugee crisis
a lot of people were forced to flee
their homes in the middle east and north
africa due to war or
political instability and this meant
that there were a lot of new arrivals on
the european continent
people who brought with them their
families their religions and their
cultures
now migration is nothing new of course
this stuff happens all the time
but the refugee crisis in 2015 really
made this subject a very hot
topic of debate not everyone was happy
about the new arrivals in europe while
others had a more welcoming attitude
but regardless of your stance on that
subject
what i think we all want is for the
process of migration and immigration
and something also integration to
function as smoothly as possible and one
aspect that is very important to
understand for this process to go
smoothly
is to understand how the backgrounds
cultural religious and so on of these
migrants
affect their experience of migration and
integration into their new home
countries
indeed religion of course is a very
significant
factor and yet it is one that many
people including a lot of politicians
don't have much knowledge about
in order for immigration policies and
processes to work smoothly
we not only need an increased religious
literacy generally
but also a better understanding of how
religion and migration
work together and how they influence
each other
so how does migration affect religion
and how does religion affect migration
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the scholarship on migration and
religion is surprisingly thin
there have been some great studies and
literature produced about religion and
migration in the united states in
particular
but not much at all about other parts of
the world like
even europe for example and of course
there probably are some significant
differences here however i do think that
some of the conclusions of the american
studies do carry over universally and
can tell us a lot about how these things
usually function
now the first thing that needs to be
kept in mind and something that should
be obvious to most people
is that cultures and religions are
internally diverse and they never come
as fixed packages this means that
migrants even if they come from the same
place and practice the same religion
can have very different ways of relating
to that religion
and in how they implement and how that
affects their lives
in well both at home to begin with but
also specifically
in their new country of residence the
sociologist peggy levitt has written a
book called god
needs no passports in which he talks
about these subjects and she says
quote moving towards a deeper religious
pluralism
also means letting go of the expectation
that cultures are coherent wholes
cultures are not made of a single
tightly woven fabric
but rather cloths of diverse changing
threads
this seems obvious to many of us but not
all religions and people are complex and
their identities can be multifaceted
there are those who are very critical
towards religion and want to see it
eradicated for example
there are also those who are what you
can call religious
exclusivists who adhere very strongly to
a specific religion and believe that
they hold a monopoly on the
truth as well as often wanting to change
the opinions of
everyone else or wanted to convert them
basically but the vast majority of
people
and migrants fall into the middle they
often have a certain loyalty to their
culture of origin of course but they are
also willing to make compromises
and adjustments to their religious faith
or practice in order to live a
comfortable life in a new place
and this is where the most significant
part of our discussion takes off
how then does the religious identities
and practices of migrants interplay with
their national identities
and new cultural contexts well in a lot
of ways actually
one thing that may be surprising to some
people is that research shows
that when a migrant moves to a new
country where they practice a different
religion for example than in their home
country this actually strengthens
their practice or their adherence
or identification with their native
religion
or in layman terms when a person moves
to a country where they practice
the majority practice another religion
they become more
religious rather than less religious or
to put it less problematically they
become
more conservative perhaps in their
native religion
take for example a hypothetical muslim
man from pakistan
who moves to a country like the united
kingdom or let's say sweden in this case
many people may expect that because they
move to a country that is very
different that is secularized and all
this that this will result in a gradual
shift away from his old culture his
native cultural religion
and they move towards a more you could
say
swedish way of life but to the contrary
in many cases it actually shows the
opposite that this
kind of experience only makes people
identify
more with their native religion it's
pretty natural really if any of us
have been on a trip or sort of vacation
to a country that is
very different from our own we often
start when we feel very out of place
we often start to identify more with our
home country
for example i've never felt as swedish
or white as when i stayed in a small
village
in southern senegal what often happens
to migrants and their religious
affiliations
is that when confronted with a new
environment that feels different
we hold on to what we feel is our own
identity or origin
as a means of safety this often results
in an increased activity
in the religious community or the
general practice of the religion
the local religious community becomes
according to martha fredericks in her
article religion migration and identity
a quote home away from home or a kind of
safe haven
quote in those situations where migrants
experience
marginalization in the destination
country religious communities also serve
as
sheltered spaces where people's dignity
and self-worth is affirmed
and where their talents are appreciated
it does also seems to be the case that
the more a migrant feels oppressed or
unwelcomed in their country of residence
the more
likely they are to turn to their culture
of origin as an identity marker
an extreme case of this is that many of
those who turn to religious
fundamentalism in europe for example
those who chose to travel to syria and
fight for isis
are often people who feel very
marginalized unwelcome
or who feel that they don't have an
identity of course there's a lot
there's one aspect of this very complex
situation but
it is definitely one um
very important factor in this kind of
behavior according to many
psychologists and and researchers but
most people aren't those people of
course and
yet religion often becomes a very
important part of the migration
experience
as already mentioned the local religious
community often becomes a home away from
home
and spaces are often created by those
communities to create a sense of
belonging
or even a kind of sacredness now i've
spent a lot of time with muslim
communities in stockholm here in sweden
or specifically with sufi communities
from west africa
and always during such meetings there is
a sense of
creating a kind of sacred space or of
making muslim space to quote the title
of barbara metcalf's excellent
book on this subject certain clothes are
worn certain
decoration or incense is used for
example music is played
all to create a sense of home or a sense
that a room or a space
feels like islam or feels like senegal
in this case
this is often known as ritualization and
is a very important part of religious
practice
it is the way or a way that sacredness
and
a specialness is created and maintained
through different means such as what i
just mentioned like wearing certain
clothing
behaving in a certain way having certain
music or incense all this
is called ritualization which creates a
sense of sacred space
but as always we must remember that
there is always diversity here
everyone reacts differently to the
experience of migration and remember
like i said in the beginning
cultures or religions never come as
fixed packages
but what is certain and very important
is that the identities of individuals
who migrate
are very complex for example we often
like to believe that when a person
migrates to a country like sweden
then that means that they will become
swedish
and all their religious activity will
take place
within sweden as a national state but
this is not how it works
in fact religious communities and
individuals are always
part of vast transnational networks
every local mosque or church is part of
these transnational networks
which shape them and the individuals
connected to them
the religious or national identities of
migrants are almost
never one-sided they tend to be as i
said very complex
people can hold often multiple
citizenships and have a loyalty to
multiple places at the same time
and this of course includes religion to
return to an earlier reference this is
actually the main subject of peg
levitt's book god needs
no passports in the book she urges us to
abandon looking at migrants simply from
the perspective of their new country of
residence
instead she argues migrants often belong
to vast
networks that span across national
borders and which often strongly
connects them with their country of
origin
and its religious communities the labels
with which people
identify are often very complex and
complicated
and rarely include only one community
migrants
often view themselves in the case of the
book as
for example both american and pakistani
at the same time
or as both hindu and american at the
same time
these religious networks manifest
themselves in vastly different ways
and varies of course from community to
community quote
they contribute financially to these
groups raise funds to support their
activities
host visiting religious leaders seek
long-distance guidance from them
participate in worship and cultural
events during the return
visits and are the subjects of
non-migrant prayers
other migrants participate in religious
pilgrimage worship certain saints or
deities
or engage in informal popular religious
practices that affirm their enduring
ties to a particular sending country
group or place
this is what we often get so wrong about
our immigration policies
we fail to see the complexities of
identity
and the transnational networks that it
includes
we should really stop looking at
religion and and
the identities of migrants through the
very narrow lands of nation states
but instead see how these vast networks
are very important for the lives of
migrants
and of course for their religious lives
for example to return again to my own
research and background
i have spent a lot of time with west
africans from the
tijani and murid brotherhoods of sufism
and when it comes to the tijanis for
example uh specifically the group of
tejanis that i've spent time with
they have a sort of spiritual religious
leader whose name is sheikh abdul rahman
badi
and who lives in senegal but despite the
fact that these live in
these two communities live in on
different continents the
community i spend time with in sweden
and the sheikh libs in senegal
there's a very strong contact between
these two
the sheikh for example visits the local
community regularly
he holds speeches about how to live well
in swedish society on how to respect
local customs and laws while also
holding on to their own tradition at the
same time
the local the diaspora community also
goes on pilgrimages to
senegal and the gambia for similar
reasons clearly then the sheikh in
senegal and the community there
has a significant impact on the
lived experience of migration and
integration for the diaspora community
in
sweden they are very much still
connected to their home country and the
religious institutions there
but at the same time they see themselves
as swedish citizens who are very
patriotic and proud of
being part of swedish society as well
respecting the laws and the customs here
in other words their identities are
complex and multifaceted
these transnational networks are in
constant conversations with themselves
and are influenced and affected by the
experiences of migrants
it is no doubt that living in a new
place also impacts and affects the lived
religions of these individuals
as martha fredericks clearly points out
in the article religion migration and
identity quote
migration affects and transforms the
beliefs practices and community
formation of the people who migrate
that much might be clear by now but
since these communities are part of
larger networks this means that the
experience of migrants
also impacts and affects those who are
still back home
quote for one sometimes migration is as
much about the people who stay behind
as it is about people who move just as
for example the
in senegal has a direct impact on the
religious beliefs
and practices of the diaspora community
so the diaspora community itself and
their experiences
have a direct impact on the religion as
practiced in the home country as well
this is sometimes referred to as the
feedback loop
and is something that is quite
understudied in this field
and yet it is a significant aspect of
the story about religion and migration
quote migration not only affects
non-migrants in destination countries
but also non-migrants in the countries
of origin are affected by migration
so far little research seems to have
been conducted into the feedback loop
investigating how migrants experiences
beliefs and practices in their new
country of residence via transnational
networks
influence and change religious practices
and beliefs in their country
of origin this is a lot to digest and we
aren't going to get lost in the
bottomless holes of academia here today
but all this points to some of the most
significant important aspects that we
need to consider
when talking about migration and
religion and how they affect and
influence each other
bottom line is this things are complex
migrants and their cultural or religious
identities are never one-sided
they don't come in fixed packages but
with a massive variety of attitudes and
experiences
if we want to achieve better policies of
immigration and create opportunities for
immigrants to thrive
feel welcomed and avoid creating
unnecessary conflicts
we need to better understand these
things we need better religious literacy
in general to understand where people
are coming from
we need to understand the complexities
of religious belief and practice
we need to understand that people's
identities are usually multifaceted
and take into account the transnational
networks that they belong to
how they affect the experience of
migration and integration
and how we can utilize all of this to
create a more pluralistic
more understanding society
i'll see you next time this video is
brought to you by our patreon community
which includes salvata iqbal because you
asked so nicely
but also some new arrivals like omar
nasir
hamad al khalifa frederick nico spiegel
yahya bashandi air conditioner and
fred cummins and of course as always i
would like to give a special
shout out to our saints like wasif khan
greg corbin adam shraeby
muhammad hanan fikri sid jafari amuletif
and a new arrival stuart cleland
thank you all so much this is really
what is keeping this channel going
i cannot express how much i am humbled
and thankful that you choose to support
me
i will leave a link to my patreon page
in the description for anyone else
interested
and i will see you in the next video
[Music]
you